mauvaise surprise pour les usagers du
ter en décembre certains ont vu la
facture de leurs abonnements mensuels
vont dire d'un seul coup une
augmentation inattendue qui arrive
peut-être au mauvais moment où on est en
plein dans un débat on va dire écolo où
il faut pas prendre la voiture
on va favoriser des transports en commun
si d'un autre côté on les augmente d'une
telle manière je pense que ça risque de
faire grincer des dents
voilà je suis étudiante donc j'ai un
budget assez réduit et je dois le
prendre quand même tous les jours
courante fan tutte semaine pour entrer
chez moi et c'est un c'est important que
ça augmente pas à partir de ce mois ci
certains usagers débourseront moins
d'argent pour voyager mais sur certaines
lignes
les augmentations iront de quelques
euros à plus de 60 euros sur un seul
mois
qui une hausse de 1 2 3 % tous les ans
ça peut s'entendre je pense
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde en est
conscient par contre qu'on est lui aussi
importante pour certains abonnements je
dis bien certains tous ne sont pas
concernés eh bien à l'ombre là pour nous
c'est effectivement pas acceptables en
l'état
de son côté la région assume ces
augmentations
sa présidente défend une harmonisation
des prix mais elle promet de corriger le
tir
nous avons considérablement baisser les
tarifs pour les occasionnels
du coup on a une fréquentation très
importante la meilleure de france
aujourd'hui on est en train de changer
les tarifs de nos abonnements on n'avait
pas fait ces augmentations depuis quatre
ans mais moi compte tenu du contexte
dans lequel on est je demande un geste
commercial
a la sncf il sera fait un effort annoncé
et promis
reste à savoir s'il sera suffisant pour
les usagers du ter